was awesome the birds did you like that
yeah it was so funny
oh where you going all the birds are
flying um
you're used to you're still doing the
show with i see sam comment you're still
doing the uh
yeah i'm doing so conspiracy uh um
[ __ ]
social club theory social club we're
doing two
we're doing we've got patreon patreon
and rockfin
which is awesome rockford because they
don't well rockfin is this
platform where you don't get censored at
all the problem with doing conspiracy
social club i can't do it on youtube we
get we get banned yeah what you can do
on patreon right
ah youtube owns patreon yeah but they
also they're just venmo they
use vimeo vimeo and then oh no sorry
patreon uses vimeo yeah and vimeo will
take you down a lot of times because
even
on a page sam gets
sam goes crazy with conspiracy theories
and i debunk them
by the way i'm losing all the time
because i made up the show there are so
much they did he goes i got it i came up
with it
i got the idea yeah now what we're doing
because it's gotten really popular it's
gotten thank you yeah
it's gotten very popular on patreon and
now rock family
it's getting there we're taking we got
55 episodes i'm listening
55 episodes we're going to take from
episode 1 all the way to 55 and release
one just
audio on everywhere you can get podcasts
starting with the first one
right so the old one the problem is we
can't release it on youtube because
they're like
you guys what audio you can do so what
happens
but on vimeo they take it down a lot of
times too they'll take it down so we
have to do we have
yeah but that's why we go go to raffin
we have to go to rockford because
rockville doesn't
no you can watch everything all right
that's insane dude it's what it's
like so you know like we'll talk about
pegging
i'm sure this [ __ ] this when i said
when we talk about pegging or
what steroids that will alert youtube
and then i can't like if i want to put
money behind promote the show youtube
won't let that's crazy like nope
it's worse than tv now it's like the
internet used to be the wild west but
what's happening
is there are there are platforms now
that are moving that are realize this
and and things like rockfin which a lot
of people are going to
which is why well spotify video
unless you're alex jones all right
spotify is pretty loosey-goosey right
june as far as i know so far
but if they barely started doing videos
like you do ads on tick-tock if you do
ads on
facebook or whatever yeah if you have i
know if you even bleep
your bad words the algorithm catches it
and then you can get demonetized and
trying to get it back as a
nightmare [ __ ] and then you get a
check mark on your page yes man and you
get three check marks they literally
like you know we've had this page for
eight years they were literally just
wiping
that's a disaster take it out that's the
episode no the entire page
will shut your [ __ ] down really yes and
that's a disaster but like
you're the bird you're debunking things
you're not listening
to sam's all for it though same beliefs
i mean that's what's great about
my favorite one the ice cube one where
he was like ice cube is a
fbi informant that started playing right
no he's right i'm gonna say the power
he's right no
no the podcast is [ __ ] oh well
no i'll tell you well you know about
hillary clinton being
uh a lizard what the [ __ ] are you
talking about here's the problem with
that with the conspiracy so sam sam
cracks me up
the reason it's great it's so much fun
it's because sam's so [ __ ] hilarious
yeah he's also hilarious like a lot of
times we do the podcast and it's just
i'm like let's just [ __ ] yeah
because because sam will be like well
hillary clinton worships satan and
drinks baby blood
and shows queen elizabeth i'm like what
and oh hitler was a roth child and still
alive do you have any evidence of this
well i would there's you can't go you
can't but youtube doesn't
that was bought up yeah so if you bring
out like you know google's bought by the
you know the leads and the uh
i go crazy also when you try to google
it yeah
we have walkville yeah right we have the
woke we have the maggot
we have most of us trying to get to work
in the middle kind of like
i'd say 90 percent yeah but then but you
also have the conspiracy theory people
yeah and and most people have lost their
faith in mainstream
media most or a lot of people but then
there's a lot of people that
like at swear by cnn or swear by fox
okay
i would say that's woke versus they call
those people sheeple yeah
but but this really isn't but it's
really interesting to see how
how this woke thing this crazy cancel
culture awoke thing that's really
sensitive it's mostly young people under
30.
it's it's it is a religion it is a form
of religion
yeah it's think about it the the church
yeah the church used to practice
exorcisms they would get the demon out
of you
or they would say you're a witch you own
cats you talk to yourself you have to be
burned
stick or drown or they would
excommunicate you it's exactly
what the woke community does but go on
that like at the ex communicate you from
the village which is basically like
cancel you from
social media platforms exactly so we
can't kick you out of the village now so
what we're going to do
is take away your voice on social media
and youtube and your ability to make
same thing is
kicking another village and you can't
make a living so you have to go over
there and you
don't get to be part of anything right
and that's what that is
why are you grabbing i'm making it i'm
listening dude get your avatar or
avatar whatever hand whatever you're um
[Laughter]
saying you look like an avatar of your
your old self all tight and purple
what were you saying right i don't even
know anymore
because i felt so good but i got
confused you're saying it's a modern day
witch hunt
it is it's it's it's people want to feel
pure
people who want to feel like they can
purify society create a utopia no racism
break down all the lines that's not not
right we were talking about
the last time with christie he goes you
know how insane the world would be if we
there's no racism like he's like what
would they do like if everything
there was a race already yeah
everything's fair like you know because
he goes what would we do no but also
here's my joke and but this is true
you can say anything you want about
communism you want to make everything
equal the problem is there are only so
many seats in front of the [ __ ] plane
life if life's a cow you're going to run
out of steak then you get the hamburger
then you get the sausage
somebody's going to be holding the lips
in the [ __ ] at the end of the day
you know nobody wants to eat that and
nobody wants to chew that heart and i'll
eat it yes
but that's what happened that well done
as long as it'll eat out right yeah
of course now you're missing the point
man oh yeah i think
we're talking about the cow oh yeah yeah
i saw where you were going as long as
you have good [ __ ] and bad [ __ ] as long
as there's a better view
the people that know how to game the
system are going to get the better view
whether that's capitalism or communism
it's never been different
you're not going to cr you're not going
to create equality
by enforcing you know a central body to
make everything equal
you know who i find how about when i get
off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler we gotta [ __ ]
together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son